good afternoon everyone my name is
Horatio I'm French general
then the point of view I'm going to
deliver you this afternoon is going to
be the point of view of a journalist I
do not pretend what I'm not
unfortunately I'm not a computer science
I'm Nate neither or an engineer I try to
work myself to surround myself with
people expect in the field I will be
presenting together with this students
evencio Joe she will introduce herself
in the in the middle of the presentation
so let me give you first an overview my
project is called deep news note a I the
first the original name was news quality
scoring that no one was able to remember
this name so I decided to go for more
straightforward name we'd like to solve
actually two problem the first one is a
massive undervaluation in quality
journalism I'm going to develop this
aspect in a moment the second one is
what I call an untapped potential for
new editorial product this is the two
things we would like to to unlock the
first question I'm having when I'm doing
this kind of presentation which is a
perfectly legitimate question is how do
you define quality I decided to narrow
down the definition of quality to the
amount of resources that are deployed by
a media organization to cover the news
and to differentiate is cover is
coverage from other organization we are
talking value-added versus commodity
news we're talking about workforce we
are talking about talent expertise
innovation but also also ethics in the
transparency in the process of of doing
doing news this is the definition so how
deep news that AI we work is pretty
straightforward let's say you are
publisher or a new distributor you
present a bunch of URL stories to an API
and it goes to a SAS platform and the
platform will render a score for each of
the story and this is an important
differentiator in the thing means that
of people are addressing the quality of
the news concerning the source where we
intend to address the quality of the
news at the story level so that this is
an important differentiator the idea is
to do that at scale automatically and
using machine learning algorithm a
reliable score makes nearly anything
possible in many different way that
could impact very positively the the
musical system the first one is
advertising I'm going to develop that in
a moment
the second point our improvement on
recommendation engine the third one is
personalization the fourth one is what I
call smart curation and aggregation and
the last one is the creation of premium
editorial product some might be paid for
some might be free but we're talking
about premium editorial product that
would be an important component for the
the economy of the news ecosystem so
let's dive into the advertising first
today the the news business is in a kind
of weird situation the news business is
the only one in which the cost of
producing a story is not passed along
the consumer when you buy an iPhone when
you buy a cheap Android chip Android
phone you will find the value of the
product passed along the the chain of
the consumer chain towards the the
customer in the case of the of the news
business it doesn't work that way if you
take this blank space on this page which
is as you see a page of the of the
Guardian regardless of the content which
is put in this page whether it is a
cheap story gossip or something which
will be put together by a couple of
interns or a super expensive story that
cost hundreds of thousands of dollars to
produce required weeks and months of
work and editing process and things the
price of the advertising you see here
will be exactly the same regardless of
the content so this is a kind of
absurdity we need to
- correct so how the stuff will work in
practice
again you are aggregator or pretty sure
you have a streams of story you submit
that to the platform the platform
process stories at the individual level
and let's say it renders a score then
you are the ad server you need to know
how their server is working for a news
company ad server as premium ads and as
non premium ads which are cheap the
premium ads are usually negotiated
directly between the platform and the
advertising the buying system it
involved usually big brands and the sick
the the the bottom of the barrel so to
speak our advertisement which are sold
automatically through programmatic and
actually I did not make this up and in
this advertisement which appears in the
Yorker sending needless to say to a fake
news site was put in The New Yorker
automatically and the nice to know to
The New Yorker obviously but there is
there is more if you take this ugly
advertising which as you can see it's in
French I capture them I can I capture it
when I was when I was in Paris last year
guess where I got it from yes I got in
from the New York Times
it's just show you how screwed up is the
current system of advertising in this
field you have a brand which is the New
York Times and I'm huge fan of the brand
I must have been one of the first among
the first subscription subscribers they
had in France I'm paying for the New
York Times and I do not regret my money
of course and but we have this thing in
which the New York Times system supply
chain of advertising work so poorly that
they can allow this kind of advertising
and needless to say the price for what
we call a mega banner in that case is
extremely inexpensive for the most
valuable piece of digital real estate
you can think of in this country and
globally so there is many things to
correct in that field so the whole idea
of the deep news system is to of the ad
server being able to detect the score of
the story and being able to adjust
the price of the advertising of the
advertising in accordance to the value
and the quality of the surrounding
editorial environment so this is
basically the idea so many people ask me
probably not you guys but I'm getting
this question quite often
why advertising should reward quality
the first one first reason is that
indicators are blinking red when you
look at the condition of advertising
currently in the news business it is
worse than before and it's actually
getting worse in terms of revenue
revenue perform at level of fraud which
is huge the viewability and the invasion
of ad blocking people especially in the
news business tends to be very
complacent with the ad blockers they
tend to say well it's not problem is to
a fifteen twenty percent that's not true
if you take tech oriented website or
worse game oriented website which is
both tech and oriented to the Year
targeted to the young audience the right
the rate of ad blockers might shoot up
ninety percent I know some site who have
this this promise so this is a big
problem second thing the brand brand
what is called a brand safety is a
measure is a major issue we have seen
that recently with YouTube it has been a
very big problem and also you need to
keep in mind that great journalism
content calls for great demographic it
is a known factor that a good story well
reported series of great article are
going to reach primarily highly educated
people quite often old people but also
affluent people which is kind of
important for the advertising ecosystem
so great content calls for great
demographics quality content is also
good for better innovative ad format
there is this thing which is kind of a
term which is not perfect it's called
native advertising and native
advertising is a kind of editorial
product which is label and fit for a
brand and this stuff works much better
in the surrounding context of a quality
editorial and the other concept is that
ROI which is the return of investment
which is the religious belief in the
advertising business is not everything
you have plenty of brands who does not
measure the ROI in a kind of mundane
fashion but are more interested to
provide information or to provide some
brand awareness or positive image of
their of their product so the second
application for the deep news dot AR
system is race recommendation engine
recommendation engine is I would say the
lowest hanging fruit in the news
business currently it is the easiest way
to increase readers engagement it has a
direct impact on the on the piano
today it works as the following it is
extremely crude you have a text a page
it will trigger it will the system will
spot some keywords and it will go to the
archive and the archives based on the
keyword will return related stories
problem is it sucks terribly it doesn't
work you have plenty of example and I
could show you plenty of example of
let's say you have a story about the
resignation of Rex Tyler tiller so let's
assume that a very inspired journalist
is going to do some kind of film movie
reference is going to say well it's like
a drama or something is going to coach I
don't know some kind of movie maker or
something director or something it is
very likely that the engine of
recommendation will actually detect the
name of the movie the director and will
serve a story according to this stuff
which has nothing to do with the bulk of
the subject so we need to address this
so there is little or no relevancy there
in there there are lots of false
positive and there are no signals
whatsoever of depth or quality and the
worst is this stuff is largely delegated
to our drain and tabula and this is kind
of amazing if you take for example a
news website to quality news website
let's take Bloomberg and let's take
Ramona in France libel is the major
newspaper in France it's like the New
York Times in this country all the
Washington Post something and Bloomberg
like it or not it's a very good
seek outlet they are polluting
constantly all of their story in the
bottom of story you will see an out
brain and or tabular actually
advertisement for really crappy stuff
and actually will show you later on that
in our model we are using our brain and
tabular reference as a bad sample of
articles so there this guy are killing
their business for the sake of short
term probably profitability the way we
see it is that in the next system we
will have the deep news platform
analyzing first the text the stream of
the text but also that all archives
these archives and the text the three
modern in the new cycle will be will go
through the platform the platform will
sign a score and we will have a precise
indicator of the quality of this of the
year of the other text so we will be
able to serve stories not based on mere
keywords but based on the real quality
of the of the text so we'll be able to
live the most qualitative stories from
the publisher archives will lift value
added based on value add value added
instead of ins keywords and the the
dials of the model the table of the
model will be able to be turned one way
another in order to serve certain
purpose for example lifting stories of a
certain age lifting story of a certain
kind and so on and so forth and it will
practically speaking increase the page
views and the session duration and it
could be included in premium
subscription it's a dress code with what
is called a zombie syndrome story this
expression is not mine it has been given
to me by a dude named Massimo Russo who
is the editor-in-chief of La Stampa and
I was presenting this stuff and he said
to me well it reminds us after the coup
in Turkey years ago we decided to of
course they were covering the news as it
happened but they decided to lead from
their archive manually literally a very
good prison story which was written a
year earlier by their political analyst
which was a perfect description of
what was the policy of our gun and
everything and this story alone was able
to translate into one Android
subscriptions of course 100 subscription
for La Stampa is not going to change the
economic up knees up knees newspaper but
if you apply this kind of stuff on a
daily basis across all the boards of the
of the publication it might affect
positively the economic of the news
business so the third thing is the
personalization and we are working in a
system which is called the queue tag
queue for quality tag concept let me try
to explain you let's assume that we have
this is a unfortunately a kind of
fictitious example but I'm pretty sure
that there is some kind of ID behind
that let's assume that we have a network
of publisher large and small the small
part is kind of important in my
reasoning you will have the Economist
you will have The Globe and Mail the
Toronto Globe and Mail you will have the
MIT Technology Review you will have
Vanity Fair you will have some kind of
fictitious future city blog now you have
the reader
this woman she subscribed to the
Economist The Economist knows a lot
about her because she knows the
Economist knows where she comes from
what she reads in the Economist what
kind of stories she likes what kind of
subjects she likes what kind of format
of story she likes the story knows this
she likes wrong forms she likes profile
of people she's working in urban studies
so we she loved urban things she is she
has she's a trained economist so she
likes global economy she likes some kind
of science and tech but she doesn't like
politics and sports which I don't like
either by the way and so this is what I
call the queue tied the queue tag is the
label of this person based on their
preference the way I see it is that in
order to be efficient this queue tag has
to be based on some kind of consent way
it means that this woman will have some
kind of trusted relationship with the
economist at some point the economists
will ask her okay
the economist is part of this network
would you agree in order to serve you
better that we could share some of your
reading information with other public
a member of the network and of course we
guarantee blah blah blah privacy's thing
but it will be good for selves you
better
so if we go this way we will have the
quality time that will travel along all
the publication that this woman will
look at across this network large
publications such as the Toronto Globe
and Mail but also specialized
publications such as the MIT Technology
Technology Review but also tiny stuff
such as the future City blog blog and so
on so the thing is when she will read
the MIT Technology Review the Technology
Review will come with is its article and
everything but also it will be able to
serve recommended stories quality
stories based on the profile and
preference expressed by this woman
through a Ritter's reading of The
Economist and it will warrant that she
will be served with super relevant stuff
so you might ask me what's in it for the
Economist for the Economist it the whole
system will work as some kind of
reciprocity the economists will will we
will serve also relevant stories from
other other publication and once you
will be reading the future the
fictitious future city blog she will
have also recommended story based on
their preferences of genres of type of
article and an end topic this could be a
super virtual system way more better
than the current out brain and tabular
nothing last thing is what I call smart
creation and aggregation again let me
take an example we take the example of
the Guardian weapons to be a partner of
our adventure the editor of The Guardian
asked every desk of the Guardian such as
the international economy science etc a
shara to come up with the whole list of
website and online publication that the
journalists are monitoring on daily
basis let's talk about we are talking
about 500 website producing thousands of
article per day it is a super
qualitative selections of website
provided by specialized journalists
but it's not possible to manage all this
output every day and problem is this
great output is not seen by the by the
reader so let's assume the following we
are this 5 500 website thousands of
article per day again it will go through
the news quality the deep user platform
and we will extract for this story we
will create the content extract the most
relevant based on their value added
quality and so on and we were able to
repackage this thing in some kind of
premium product for the benefit of the
reader for instance in newsletter that
could be paid for newsletters of super
high quality high level relevant stuff
so the whole system benefits the musical
system across the board new product
opportunities increase of the
destination notion dimension of news
website which has been largely escaped
to the benefit of other players I mean
the problem is with news news site right
now there are no longer destination
websites there is no more leakage to
other player like aggregators Korean
characters and stuff there will be more
time spent by the reader a deeper
engagement more loyalty and last but not
least more revenue so how we intend to
build it we are actually working on to
model the first one is the feature based
model relying on signals I'm going to
develop that is done by a PI at my
teammate in Paris and the second one is
a deep learning base it's done here at
Stanford at the CS 2:30 class by a group
of students so very quickly the feature
base model it relies on a list of
signals that we put together in which we
love for instance an analysis of the by
lines the by lines is super important
stuff when you think about it the byline
will tell you could tell you about the
notoriety of the journalist it could
tell you for instance how important the
byline is for the publisher if behind
byline you have a link that sends the
reader to the whole body of work of the
journalist sends the reader to the
biography of the journalist it means
that there is a will for transparency
and and qualitative assessment
of the author or the article so we're
going to look at the photo for instance
the youth of the photo the use of the
video if does it choose stock footage
does it credit properly the photography
and stuff then we are going to do some
kind of text analysis the word count is
the most abused but it's not by far the
only the main signals name entity the
number of named entities can be
important a quote analysis the number of
people quoted we're going to do a series
of reading ease assessment and we are
going to look at the structure including
sometimes the punctuation structure
that's going to be what I call
quantifiable signals in order to be
complete we are also going to rely on
signals that cannot be or at least at a
large scale retrieved by a machine we
call that subjective signals and we that
was the initial list we have story time
writing thoroughness balance and
fairness etc etc we decided to test this
through some kind of dedicated interface
that will be put on light in a online in
a few day this is the prototype right
now so people make an evaluation of a
story they pick up a story they make an
evaluation of the different component
and they give a global score and the
signals we are asking for has been
narrowed down to the story type the
thoroughness the balance and fairness
the life span which is a very important
factor of the life span and what I call
the importance and relevance and again
to global score and then we have the
deep learning natural language
processing and I turn to you Joe who is
going to deliver you deliver you the
noises like what yeah I mean even more
important yeah so into so my teammates
and I were given this wonderful
opportunity to work with Fredrik and his
news quality scoring project through a
class we're taking and these are my
teammates this is actually still at a
very early stage and
it's very experimental and I almost want
to temper your expectations by saying we
don't quite have major results yet but
we wanted to share some of the
techniques and approaches that we have
been experimenting with so before we
delve into the technical details of our
models we as a team sort of step back
and asked what is quality news what do
we want our model to classify as call it
high or low quality news and we broke
down this nebulous idea into sort of
concrete dimensions that range from
finer and broader from finer to broader
definitions and in on the sort of the
finer end we have more you know easily
quantifiable things such as a structure
of a sentence the writing elements and
conciseness even the density of
information but we have on the broader
spectrum narrative arc various scopes
teams and theses if present at all and
what journalists call an angle and these
we all hoped we worked with the
assumption that our deep learning model
would be able to capture some of these
qualities of quality news so as with all
supervised learning tasks we were faced
with this big problem of human labelled
data and we calculated that each news
article costs about a dollar for human
reading labels and given we were working
or we're hoping to work eventually with
four million articles our budget could
not handle a human labeling of our
entire data set so we instead what we
did is rely on the reputation of the
news providers so for instance The
Economist has a great reputation for
producing consistently high quality news
articles and so we labeled all articles
coming out of the Economist as high
quality and for professional purposes I
would not go into which brands we've
classified as producing low quality news
but this is just a small selection of
but but our model look awesome so so
this is a small selection of some of the
news providers that we're working with
and
we're still currently in the process of
collecting and labeling our data we
eventually hope to have more than even
four million and we actually are in the
process of late working with human label
data as well just a smaller set not four
million and in this process we found
that there are several caveats and the
biggest caveat especially when working
with deep learning with this data set is
that because we are working with the
assumption that higher quality
well-reputed news providers would
produce good quality news that means
that in effect our models are trained to
learn how to classify based on the house
styles of the different news providers
either in other words if a news article
if an unlabeled news article comes in
and it's written in the form of The
Economist maybe it's a former economist
writer then it would be classified as
high-quality and in a way that's sort of
what we want but there's other problems
with that and one is that we have the
problem of topical bias because some of
these news providers tend to have I tend
to discuss topics that are for instance
heavy on business or finance so the
Economist for instance or the Financial
Times and this means that when you have
an unlabeled article coming in talking
about economics or business it would be
highly rated towards high quality
because of the presence of certain
topical words and then we also had the
other problem of working with contempt
you know it's not really historical
because I'm actually historian and
history means you know like at least
twenty years back but on so there's sort
of the the temporal bias because our
data set is from the past and because of
you know the nature of news is that news
is contemporaneous and so if our data
set of The Economist comes from ten
years ago then topics from ten years ago
would be present in the topical words
and so what we did is we wanted to
completely eliminate eliminate topical
bias by replacing them with part of
speech tags and here we were inspired by
a style um it works in style Amma tree
and there's a huge emphasis
on function words or stop words words
such as is the a and how they are used
together in sentences and punctuation so
we kept function words part of speech
tags and punctuation replaced we've
replaced all on topical words so this is
an article from The Economist you know
as expected it's a it's an economic
topic we take the text and then we
convert it into this format and this is
exactly the text that goes into our
models and so in order to test whether
this was a good idea to you know to to
tag out to mask out a big chunk of our
data we decided to very quickly test it
into in a feed-forward Network and this
is I'm sure you're all very familiar
with this network this is an affine
Network where all the neurons are
connected to the next layer so the
procedure is just very standard
continuous bag of words model where we
take the Kotok ins and for each token we
take the corresponding pre-trained word
embeddings and then we take the average
element wise and feed it into our affine
network with a binary prediction at the
very end these are some of the
preliminary results we got and as you
can see it's actually quite promising
one because you can see that our
accuracy is quite high and you know it's
not perfect but it is a baseline we're
not learning even the structure of
sentences at this point um and what's
interesting is that you can see that the
POS tag devtest it starts to over
perform the raw text which is
interesting and what we expected because
it's serving a sort of a regulator so
that it's not biased against some of the
topics that appear and then the next and
from here we're still working on this
and we have these models planned and we
are experimenting and we are currently
training language models right now but
this is the next obvious step which is
to use a sequence model very commonly is
in NLP for their ability to learn
sentence structures and so a sequence
model you know
takes in that every time step the the
next word embedding and then here we
just have a very simple an acceptor
model where we make a binary
classification at the very end is it a
good or a high or low quality news and
then here we're training we're working
with the language model a language model
is again a sequence model but the
difference is that at every time step
we're making a prediction of the next
word and we're training to because the
language model is not designed to be
actually a classifier we've made some
arrangements so that um it's able to
classify in the end and so here we have
two separate language models the first
language model is trained solely on
commodity news and the second model is
trained solely on quality news so we're
almost purposefully biasing the model so
that the two models are learning our
training weights that are are very high
or very low quality and so that's our
first stage of training and then in our
second stage of training what we're
doing is we introduce actually a a
discriminator model which is an actual
model that makes a binary prediction and
the input for this discriminative model
is actually the output from the feed
feed-forward stage of the two language
models and specifically we're taking the
softmax probability of the next time
step the t t plus 1 time step at every
time step so that at the end of the
iteration we have a 1 by T vector from
the two language models and we feed that
in as a into our discriminator so that
this discriminator is learning to make
the binary prediction and so we still
have other works in progress this
includes comparing our results our deep
learning results with more traditional
machine learning methods such as the SVM
with bigram inputs which is served to
which is shown to be very powerful and
text classification methods and we also
have we're still kind of working with
human labelled data which is a matter of
economics so that we can finally reduce
our reliance on use provider reputation
and these are our sponsors and thank you
for your attention stay here because I
might have some technical questions I
won't be able to answer if you have
question that's the at the right moment
thank you for your attention sir on some
smaller news publications like even San
Jose Mercury News a certain proportion
of their content will just be pulled
from sources like Associated Press so
the content in that case largely going
to be the same from publication of
publication modular the edits that each
publication might do before posting it
as their contents I'm kind of curious
how that impacts it since its kind of
it's almost identical
that is exactly why we are approaching
the problem at the article level because
in the same in the same edition or in
the same 24 hours of publication and for
the San Jose Mercury News you might have
shallow articles we call that community
news which is totally different from
fake news that may insist on this it
might be simply a story that just
happened the reporter doesn't have the
time to do his or her job and they're
going to produce an article that will be
fairly a fairly shallow so when it come
to the news agency first of all we can
say that we just injecting the not in
the model yet but in the in the research
we are doing we just inject 800,000
articles from Reuters that will be
analyzed by itself and it's interesting
because for two things the first one is
that news this news wire dispatches
articles are written in the same way
they are abide to they are built on a
same kind of structure and they tend to
be fairly reliable and it
very thorough editing process and stuff
so yes you might have the same story
appearing in several newspaper that's
the that's the that's the thing but we
won't affect them all because we are we
want to be able to detect the story that
requires a very great journalistic work
typically in the case of the San Jose
Mercury News you might have an in-depth
story which which is going to be an
investigative piece about I don't know a
land zoning in Silicon Valley next to a
shallow article about something and our
model will be willing to detect and to
assign a different score from one to
five we hope differently being able to
differentiate the shallow story to the
in-depth story that is the the goal yeah
I mean feel free to tweet or check by
the way because I don't that is the big
that is the big problem the
differentiation this is exactly what we
are we want again what we want to to
work at the at the at the article level
not at the story level and this make
this makes the the problem of labeling
story quite crucial and actually one of
the next step we will have will have
access to it was not the case
unfortunately for building the current
model the students are working on but we
would have access to a thousand a 10,000
stories that will have been labeled by a
third-party company they will have
analyzed for instance the time and
engagement for each story the depth they
will put a pixel for instance in the
page to be able to see if the people the
readers actually go to the bottom of our
story or do they remain at the top of
the story so that will be an indicator
well indicate well what are the
indicator will be the length of a story
other indicators will be quote
American journalism rely a load a lot on
quotes so we might be able to
differentiate the story by the density
and they actually the volume of
information that are that are in a story
but my our goal is very clear we want to
be able when the thing turn Post for
instance which is mostly a fairly
shallow news provider and to be frank we
put that in in the quadric to get the
category of shallow news provider
sometimes it the laughington post having
the pulse yeah the whole idea is to be
able to detect if the effington post is
actually running running dev stories it
is even more important for very tiny
website the goal of this model I don't
think we will be able to achieve that in
a near future but the ultimate goal of
the model is being able to find to
detect the quality of a small blog I
always take the example I have a blog
which is called the Monday node in which
Monomoy my colleague is name is John
wick si Yun hearth an amazing blog the
guy is written by some retired engineer
in Seattle the guy is highly specialized
in metallurgy and the way that that
iPhones for instance are manufacture and
stuff the guy was able to write a series
of amazing stories based on his
knowledge of the way that piece of
aluminium are actually mailed and so on
these are unique pieces and this is
exactly the kind of pieces I'd like our
star to be able to to detect and to lift
quality pieces even though the supplier
I mean the output of this guy working
probably alone is fairly small and do
you have a question
it is actually very straightforward I
mean the choice of these two you are
free you're already tabular and another
one is called red content and we
actually analyze a million stories
coming from this from these guys it is
very straightforward these three
companies are actually paying the
publisher up from with some with a very
high minimum guarantee throughout this
story displayed the problem is it is a
completely powered system because the
problem is not only our brain our tabula
are getting paid by other kind of small
publisher they are going to aggregate
but they are going to get paid because
they are going to aggregate all the
reading data coming from the main
publisher for instance Bloomberg for
instance LeMond for instance played
plenty of others like Business Insider
and stuff and they're going to resell
the data so the publisher is screwed
twice first of all it is totally
disfiguring its content
by undermining the credibility I mean
when you think about it it is completely
absurd you will have a piece written by
a bunch of journalists we will have
spent many hours right working on their
stuff and at the bottom of it
you will have a story which will say
learn Russian in in three weeks or the
celebrities blah blah and so on to me
it's a kind of insult to journalists
that's why by the way the New York Times
one was one of the very few to actually
refuse that and the newsroom actually
refused to up this kind of this kind of
stuff display it's purely a question a
question of money so on their best
disfiguring their pages and they are
leaking data to other stuff and as you
know data is a super important important
thing sir signals advertisers currently
get likes early from Facebook and Google
and other parties they'll get
information about the target of the
advertiser been classified by Facebook
or Google and they use that and figuring
out how much to bid how much information
to the
the site where it's actually going to
appear and could have publishers say
well this is a you know but this was an
expensive article for us so if you want
it you want to place an article here
then - we're gonna ask Google about the
quality of the ad the school ranks the
quality of ads camera and and we'll make
you pay more
first of all advertisers they have a
tons of data about the quality of the
science surrounding stuff yeah
they get that because they are able to
conduct the same kind of analysis than
we do and they they like to have an idea
of what of what we surround the
advertising the problem is there they
don't want to use it very much so right
now so in theory they could be able to
do they bit more I think it's a good no
it'll be more but the thing is we I
wouldn't have started this project if I
hadn't have clear signals from the
advertising community and actually they
would be interested in by this kind of
stuff the ability to score stories at
the at the individual level at the story
level and and actually when you win for
instance I got a call cold wall because
I they reach out to me from from group M
which is the media buying entity for WPP
in in London which is the largest media
buyer in the world and I don't know if
you have seen the news recently WPP as
release some super bad result with a
drop in their revenue and drop in their
profitability yeah it's a very big
tremor in there oh it's simply because
the platform is are eating their lunch
and the guy I talked to is say to me
that actually they might be interested
to talk with us about quality because
they believe that it could be some kind
of credible refuge or credible way to
actually lift the unitary value of the
advertising module so there is
definitely something here my problem is
that I'm more jealous than an
advertising guy and I would be more
willing to work with
whisper be sure than advertiser since
I'm also pragmatic stand I need money to
pay for smart engineers I would I would
probably we try to sell my stuff to
advertiser papers is something years
later if your system could take an
article and empty you know something
fine art will take care of suit later
recognize whether what he said is true
in the life of history and you could get
some some some scoring some of true
story as to whether whether this source
really just concise yeah although not
yes
yeah and that could be an indicator that
that's why one of the very important
indicator we are looking for is the life
span of a story you have stories which
have a value of a few hours some few
days some weeks and months and some are
what we call evergreen what were you're
referring to is the evergreen story the
ability to measure evergreen story but
the whole thing would like the thing
we'd like to be able to achieve it is
being able to detect the characteristic
of an evergreen story right from the
outset just to give you an idea we are
with another student he's working alone
with another student working in that
kind of different data set the guy but
on the same kind of reasoning we are
working on the guy decided to go to take
all the Pulitzer Prize story which will
be a kind of gold standard of quality
journalist and he wants to extract all
the quality all the features all the
hidden features of Pulitzer Prize which
I think it's an interesting idea not it
there is no commercial application to it
but I think it's interesting lead and we
intend to work with them
also who wrote it like in the Bible
who wrote what
yeah except it's some sometimes
unconstitution an open medicine yeah who
copied from home yeah but the auto-ship
sometimes I mean an evergreen story a
story that will have a real impact might
be written by some kind of an unknown
person so I mean the notion can you can
tell if it's the same or the same yeah
knowing you recognize the water great
the water Watergate break-in us as a
seminal story when it first came out
that really seems hard interesting story
honestly we don't I mean if I'm
completely honest with you we don't what
we will I don't know what you what you
think about this that what we might be
able to detect is a kind of pattern in
the photo web stories so we might be
able to detect the fact that this story
is gaining in importance because the
Washington Post in that case is devoting
a greater efforts to actually report the
stories on a writ kind of regular basis
assigning more people talking to lots of
people around this story and I think I
don't know what you think but I think we
might be able to detect low low low
level signals lonely low level signals
for this kind of this kind of thing
because in terms of history I think that
they're actually we're talking about
primary sources you know reading 20
years ago or you know the Watergate I
think that an article that is quality
may not it it could maybe it's not
making the right claims at the time of
its publication but I think it was still
it could still be quality news because
it could still be quality primary source
because I think a quality piece of
writing would not make outrageous claims
that this is exactly
true and it would be shown through in
the the style of writing this gentleman
was waiting to ask question could you
say a little bit more about what you're
trying to accomplish with feeding the
text when you remove the topics and just
have the part of speech tags and the
function words in - yeah so where the
part one of the reasons why we're
eliminating so much original data by
masking them out with POS tags is
because we have sort of a big bias in
our data set so I mentioned to you we
have first because we don't have human
label data we have the problem of
relying on the quality of the news
providers and we are heavily skewed
towards news providers that talk about
Business and Finance topics and so we
don't want to make the mistake of
incoming test articles that that
happened to talk about Business and
Finance to be labeled quality just
because they have certain topical words
with high frequency and then there's a
second which is that because Muse is
instantaneous it's it's supposed to be
reporting what happened very recently
our data set timelines are not exactly
aligned for all the news providers that
we work with so I think for the
Economist we have the last ten years and
then for I think the Google dump it's
the last 15 years or something like that
and so we have this problem of certain
topics that arise you know with high
frequency 15 years ago and then we have
different topics out of I arise with
high frequency 10 years ago right so we
want to eliminate the temporal and use
provider reputation bias or a topical
biased style writing like it might you
know weigh in right yeah yeah so it's
heavily inspired by style AMA tree and
authorship attribution we and so we're
hoping that because we have a wide
variety of wide
of writers and source providers that we
would be capturing general quality
writing style rather than you know
Hamilton writing for you know New York
Times actually out of you I just go do
the same analysis and then do bathrooms
right well I mean you could have an
article about the Kardashians that is
quality I don't think that all articles
that talk about the Kardashians could be
[Laughter]
cute asked have you talked to Washington
Post and pick somebody else and ask them
the questions will you share data about
your viewers your readers with someone
else in return for information about
their readers actually I this that's
good question at this very moment none
of them will because the for couple of
reasons the first one is I was quite
involved in France and in Europe in some
kind of collective initiative when it
comes to try to put publisher together
and having them to share stuff this is
not an industry which is willing to
share which is kind of weird to me I'm
living I'm from Europe in which you have
the the cell phone company cell phone
carriers which are find quite often for
collusion on price and and stuff like
that none of this stuff is happening in
the in the news publishing business
these people are not are not willing to
share the desktop having say that
personal item I may be too optimistic
attentively that if we are able to show
them the benefit of sharing some of the
data in some kind of close trusted
environment of the fictitious network of
ours I was referring to I think this
kind of stuff could work if you take
quality publication like the wall I was
mentioning in my in my high
example I think if you are able to
create some kind of fairly small network
of high quality publication which will
be better the one against each other
then these people might be willing to
share some of the data because I mean I
mean it will be fairly easy to show them
that if for the MIT Technology Review we
are able to show some kind of readers is
coming the alleys the lady fictitious
coming to the to look at the MIT
technology reduce review and she sees
some stories from other publication we
might be able to tell to the members of
the network that there is indeed a
benefit because we can go a bit further
I mean I'm I've been giving a lot of
thinking on this let's assume for just a
second that the MIT Technology Review as
a paywall which is which is quite
assumable they are paid for but they
don't have a payroll a metal paper let's
say that you are for instance I don't
know three three article per month that
are free and then you need to pay if
they see this person coming this person
is some kind of occasional reader but
she is definitely interested is in
something which is urban studies and so
on and so forth at the MIT Technology
Review is covering some time to time I
think it would be wise for the MIT
Technology Review to open just a little
bit up a wall in order to say to this
occasional customer hey okay you seem to
be interested so let's give you a trial
offer for two months and you will see
the inside of the of the store and stuff
that's the first thing they should be
very well advised to do the second thing
is pricing I don't believe that
everybody is willing to pay the same
price for the same service if we take
this again fictitious female reader she
might be willing let's say let's assume
that the cost the price of the MIT
Technology Review is 15 bucks a month
this person she reads sometimes a story
I mean maybe once a month
the technology review she might not be
willing to pay 15 bucks a month because
I mean the value is simply not there if
after having seen the behavior of this
person the MIT Technology Review is able
to determine patterns of conception and
make some kind of assessment on how much
she might actually be willing to pay
they might be coming to the conclusion
that the best deal for this person will
be for ninety nine months which is
better than nothing and this is my view
of the payroll system but unfortunately
if we are very far from it and I need to
come back to your question how to
convince publisher that they should go
to some kind this kind of odd model is
precisely to build models in which they
will see the benefit of having some in
the example I was thinking about the MIT
review a long tail of brand-new
subscriber they don't have access to
that might be willing to pay between
four and nine dollars per per month
which is again way better than nothing
[Music]
becoming stricter and stricter clearly
now third party cookies websites if you
tags are implemented in such a way even
if a person is interested in it they
might not true it would be the same base
in Europe with the GDP error thing that
could restrict to the financier I - this
is that's why I insist on the fact that
this tag has to be some as to become
sons base I mean I am the subscriber to
human male I have a kind of trust
relationship and if the Toronto Globe
and Mail mail asked me would you might
accept to share some information you
would be would you be okay if we share
some information about your reading
patterns in order to serve you better in
some kind of content and trusted
environment me even though I'm kind of a
suspicious guy I will tend to say yes I
might be wrong but I think it's it's
it's it's it's quite a possibility
because against we might be able to so
as long as this stuff is respected ie
content consent not content consent
based cookie so to speak
tag I think it could work by the way the
same problem applied to the regulation
that will be in plenum implemented next
May in Europe which is called the GDP or
something which is going to be a super
big problem for the for the publisher so
you had a question yes it was and it's
just too much trouble to set up 15
different accounts to pay them so
instead I use all the trickery I know
get around the payrolls yeah nothing and
I use it ad blocker okay this is their
business model many people many people
many people it's a big problem but you
know what I mean I assume that if you
take I can see what kind of publication
you are you might be you might be
reading and I doubt that you might be
willing to pay the full maybe I'm wrong
but I doubt that you might be willing to
pay the full price for each of the
publication because it will cost you a
bundle in the end oh yeah yeah so they
had some kind of publication service
where I get said you know pay one fee
and depending on my usage it wasn't too
much I'd be willing to do that 15 of
them forget it yeah 15 that in our
bridge of $9 or $12 a / - it's going to
be just the overhead of trying to
maintain the 15 subscriptions
I don't think maintaining maintaining
the account is a problem I think that
at some point the the check that it
really take to your discredit
discretionary revenue the model you the
money you we are willing to spend to
spending this kind of thing will be a
problem because I in the end it might
cost you a fairly big amount upon a year
each year and you might not see the
value for a publication that you look at
a couple of times in the month and you
if they ask you 15 bucks you said no no
no but if they ask you 5 baht you might
say oh five bucks it's a price of an
expresso at Stanford so so sir and then
you sir yes why can't I pay something
for a single user or double use or
something why do they want to force me
into a subscription thing immediately
and go for a one-time use with a
one-time asperger's the question of the
one-time use you mean by that the fact
and that princeton spain article by the
piece you mean do you mean by for
instance paying article by the piece by
for instance paying i don't know five
cents and an article and stuff i must
say that as a former executive in
publishing companies rather against the
idea of unbundling the news content
because when you look at the map the
math it doesn't add up for the publisher
it's it is the one of the best way to
actually kill the business because the
unitary price even multiplied by certain
patterns of consumption will never
replace the 10 bucks a month
subscription in terms of direct income
from the publication so it could be kind
of could be kind of tricky yeah that's
another thing
we can do that with screen down to your
friend oh well if you if someone is
extremely poor he or she can find an
super easy way if someone has the time
they can find all sorts of way to look
at things for free I mean you you will
have four browser on your computer might
have two computer you might have two
mobile devices I mean no problem of pain
except for hard paywall such as the
world's regional ordered all the the
financial times but you will miss some
stories but I mean when you consider the
value of a story and there replicability
of a story of our times somebody else
will soon pick up that story exactly
wait that's what I anyway yeah to find
it my my take is what we pay in a
subscription to a new service we pay
convenience yeah we pay quick fast
access we pay okay
I look at the worst the Washington Post
every morning on my tablet I don't want
to be bothered by juggling into my
different browser and stuff i ok I've
half an hour to pour over the three main
outlet I'd like to have a look at and I
pay for that convenience but if money
becomes scarce I will reconsider and I
don't want to be perfectly willing to
spend a certain amount per year to have
a certain review next to the articles
and magazines saying that the Associated
editors of America rank the accuracy of
this story and the relevance for they're
just a couple of simple scalars and they
would give me a clue as to whether a
body of people that I trust these that I
respect
hmm
yeah actually it's funny that you
mentioned that and because because in my
blog I keep constantly referring to
Netflix which is in my view there
the operating system of the other video
market in this country I'm and abroad of
course and I think we have a lot of
stuff to draw from the inspiration of
next flicks week actually Netflix when
it comes to the biggest problem we have
which is the labeling the data Netflix
is doing a lot of data labeling by the
end you know there are thousands
literally thousands of genres of film
and they have actually human which are
who are paid kind of super paid couch
potato people who actually watch movie
and say okay it is a story of an old guy
with a mustache living in 19th century
falling in love with an Indian woman and
so on and so forth a super granular
convenience and it is spotted it is
definitely part of the year or next
prints recommendation and gene just very
statistically years ago just to give you
an idea of the amount of money that
netflix has poured in its recommendation
engine few years ago I was used to be
the the digital guy head of digital
operation for the major business news
provider in France it's called les echo
and it turns out that at this time the
revenue of the this newspaper and the
payroll the staff of newspaper who
was exactly the same than the budget of
Netflix recommendation engine and the
number of people which were and provide
Netflix recommendation engine in that
case 300 people for a budget of 150
million dollars plus or minus the
conversion in euros but same roughly the
same figures it just gives you an idea
how much this guy at Netflix has been
visionary when it come to say ok we are
this huge library of stuff on the long
run we are going to produce a whole
bunch of content because Netflix is
going to invest 8 billion dollars and is
scheduled to produce hate and red pieces
of new Netflix original this very year
so they decided that taking the long
view they say well we are going to need
to label this kind of stuff and in order
to be able to exploit it later on that's
why I mean and even so has been quite
convincing because she should keep
yelling at me that the data are not
cleaned the they are not labeled and
stuff but of course she she is
absolutely rife with that and one of the
asset we are I think creating right now
and it's it is my short on objective is
to be able to take the millions of
article we have and finding ways to
label most of them in a most granular
fashion this is one of the of the goal
because because after that we will be
able to to come up with a lot of
different kind of model and flavor of
machine learning and deep learning
things and so as they need to have
machines and people that are in this
curation
I've seen some funding proposals with
maybe you are they required you have as
so many curators as the people
generating the content I think that they
have maybe there's some tools for yeah
actually I think one of the thing we
want to do is is having machine and
people working on to and the last thing
I want to develop although I'm very
passionate we stay with technology and I
enjoy very much having conversation with
people like and say oh about about a
deep learning in model the last thing I
want is building a step that will be
totally extraneous from from a human
approach you need to consider however
one thing which is currently nearly
every day a channel like the biggest of
all Facebook is dealing news is dealing
with 100 million links per day half of
them are in English roughly speaking
this is a figures which has been
confirmed to me by feedly so many of you
use feedly and the guy at Philly they
build an infrastructure which is able to
deal with under 100 million links half
of them in English it means that at some
point we need to rely on machine in
order to do some kind of of testing
analyzes and stuff because simply the
the pipe the pipe is too big this is the
issue I'm having with fact-checking
I'm an old guy I mean all journalists
and I've been I've been based in my
career with facts and so on and so forth
I was lucky enough to work for
absolutely great publication in which
facts were sacred so I know quite a bit
about this thing the fact of the matter
is sorry for the pen but the fact of the
matter is that
checking is great is necessary it is
extremely well done especially in this
country but the fact of the matter is
pad checking is a tiny tiny drop in the
vast ocean I used to say that it's like
pretending Puri thing pretty pure off'
eyeing the the Ganges River one glass at
the time picking up for God's sake Oh to
clean up this guy this glass oh it's
super clean right now and ignoring the
square meter thousands square
[Applause]
you